I'm Prue Lee and I'm Paul Hollywood and
we're here to answer your baking
questions that you've sent in from
Twitter this is baking support
[Music]
first up blue Starsky I can't believe I
didn't know about this what are you
looking for when you knock on the bread
do you know if you look at that I'm not
sure sure whether you can I mean it's a
baguette but if I get the bottom
yeah it sounds like it's hollow hollow
means it's got air inside it's got air
inside it's more open if it's open it's
a good bread Colleen why is my pie crust
always soggy it's a great lizard what
have you got it's a proper American Pie
a few minutes
if you've got a soggy crust it comes
down to the liquid that's inside you
need to evaporate some of that liquid
out or don't put as much liquid inside
if you've got apples cook out your
apples slightly to evaporate some of
that liquid so by the time you've got
your topping on it doesn't soak into the
middle and end up with a just a hideous
soggy milk
that's quite
dense
I've never seen any of the light there
wow oh you know another trick if you're
putting a wet mixture in like um stewed
apples or plums or something is if you
put a bit of semolina a thin layer of
semolina or polenta in the bottom it'll
soak up some of the juices and it makes
a tremendous difference and also vent
it's a vent your pastry so it allows
that steam he means make a hole in the
top
I think the Americans will know what
venting is what it could be hyperventing
that's true yeah put a hole in the top I
want to see it'll be fine from truly
croissant how do they get so flaky but
it's all about lamination so it's about
chilling the dough and the butter each
time you put you do a fold so you need
to do turns of butter and down butter a
dough so you start off with basically a
pizza dough butter covering two-thirds
of it fold that over so you end up with
dough but Adobe today
you then put that in the fridge chill
down the butter again so it goes hard
roll that out fold it again and that's
called the turn you need to do that at
least three times every time you fold it
it breaks the butter up so it looks like
a marble by the time you've finished it
you need to roll it down to about five
millimeters and then cut them into
triangles roll them up and they have a
beautiful croissant you know I've got a
cross on here and let's have a look at
this inside
that's nice and Flaky yeah
there's elimination in the flake
it means layers and layers but the fact
is you need to read a recipe about how
puff pastry is made and then you will
understand Faye my cookies are never
gooey they always go flat and hard and
spread away too much on the tray what's
the secret the mix is probably far far
too wet if it's floating that much you
need a little bit more flour in there
just to bring the mixture together and a
good little secret is when you're doing
cookies make a little indent when it's
on the tray and pop a little bit of
chocolate in the middle and then just
seal it up but with that extra bit of
chocolate on there so when you break it
open the gooeyness the chocolate will
just fall out and it's delicious we've
got a cookie here I would say that's not
a good cooking I don't think it's a good
cookie and I'll tell you for why it's
bone dry and I could tell that soon this
one had the opposite problem of what
Faye is concerned about because it
didn't they didn't spread enough
it's awful it's so sad because I thought
the most reliable American bake is a
chocolate chip cookie they're always
delicious and this one ain't
Frasier my caramel cheesecake burst and
created cracks in the surface what could
have caused this mix is too dry it's far
too dry the oven's too hot oh
if this is a cheesecake you know if you
take it out of a very hot oven into a
cool kitchen it'll often crack if it's
over Dawn what you can do and you bring
it out the oven rather than putting on
the side of the bench place the whole
thing on a cool surface like the floor
and what often happens is rather than
collapsing on itself it'll naturally
find its actual level and level off
again so rather than putting it on the
side where the this heat rising from the
floor put it on the floor gently and
then leave it to cool magusta Sparkles
yeah what is parchment paper made out of
silicon next question this is Robin can
you fix a dough that has too much flour
yes you can and if you've got a lump of
dough that's quite stiffy that whatever
done wrong you've added too much for our
by mistake add a little bit of water if
you add too much it'll just mix and
there'll be wardrobe everywhere a little
bit of water at the time take your time
mixing it take it it goes to a sticky
stage and then it begins to go inside
once it goes inside again and it's
cleared the bowl a little bit more water
and then stop the machine touch it and
feel it so it's nice and soft so yes you
can are you sure yeah why is my cake
crittering in the middle I used to be so
good at me
sometimes when things are taught you
scroll the outside and then as it begins
to carry on bacon you bring it out or
you're opening the door the middle bit
will collapse in so it comes down to the
temperature make sure you're returning
the right temperature Chef Phil what
baking tool could you not live without
it's got a scraper for me it was always
like my it's the chef's knife it's like
a wooden handle or plastic handle with a
blade a rectangular metal just to scrape
down a bench and cut up there and lift
up pastry bug bug turret why is my cake
so wrinkly
it looks like an elephant's foot it
comes down to the temperature it looks
like it's been blistered and it's a
little bit too high in temperature so
drop the temperature and you'll be fine
Mia Nona she says please don't call me a
monster but what is the point of
unsalted butter in baking unless you
need to consume less sodium most of our
recipes are actually
unsalted butter because then you can
control the amount of butter if you put
unsalted butter in you're still
controlling the amount of salt in that
recipe and that's the only reason really
and you know what the trick is is
tasting it I mean I taste all raw
mixtures all doughs all everything in
the mixing State because that's when you
can tell how much salt there is you're
not a monster you're a clever woman I'm
dizzy the Great British baking she would
be like the babco is a bit stodgy in it
and I pretend like I know what they mean
stodgy is something that's slightly
gooey but slightly stiff with a bit of
glutes gluteless quality to it
not good from dawn Bennett baking
Twitter I need your help blackened
bananas May or yay for banana bread yes
absolutely because the flavor is all
there and so I tell you one amazing
trick with blackened bananas is you cut
the two ends off just the tips leaving
the skin liquidize it in yogurt with a
bit of cinnamon and a bit of sugar if
you must it is absolutely delicious bit
of ice cream there makes it a smoothie I
bet that's not very nice you'll find
that your local Grocers if they've got
some really black bananas they'll
probably end up really giving it to you
nothing because you're about to throw it
away anyway so go to your local grocery
if you don't see anything are you going
to throw those out I'll take you end up
with a very low costing banana bread
I'm so confused how do cupcakes know
when to stop Rising it depends on the
amount of rising agent you put in so
there's a limit so if you've got lots
and lots of bacon it'll just pour if you
put a set amount in which is the point
in writing a recipe then it will stop at
a certain point and that's that's that's
basically all it is yeah you don't need
to worry about about the cupcakes
they'll worry about when they'll stop
rising from Lefty Lucy yeast is alive
yes it is and if it's dead it won't work
if it's dead it won't work yet because
what it's doing is breathing and giving
off gas which fills up the dough and
that makes the dough rise young tax
evasion that's a good name how do you
make the dough sour sourdough's been
around for around four and a half
thousand years the ancient Egyptians
invented it you need to harness
lactobacillus which is the airborne
bacteria by mixing flour and water
leaving it to rise for a few days throw
in half out feeding it with more water
and flour leaving it for a couple of
days will begin to Bubble every day you
need to throw a little bit away and feed
it feed it feed it so it takes a week to
make you start at least 10 days to two
weeks to make a very solid starter once
you've fed it after a couple of weeks it
should bubble within eight hours that
tells you can use it and you use that in
your mixture of with your flour and your
salt instead of using the bake of the
yeast that you buy in the shops this is
from muffdog Seven okay our scones
supposed to be dry and hard why is
anyone choosing to eat dry hard pastries
the secret with a good score is not to
overbake it so you want plenty of liquid
it's quite a wet mixture and once you've
cut it and you put it in the oven you
glaze a little bit of egg on the top you
bake it I normally bake it at 200 or 400
for around well not around exactly 15
minutes and you'll be spot on every time
this is Trisha of course we can't say
your handle what is the difference
between baking powder and baking soda
baking powder has baking soda in it but
it also has packing agents in there as
well so a baking soda will react with an
acid and Alkali to create bubbles carbon
dioxide which will create the growth if
any moisture gets into baking powder
it's sorted protected whereas baking
soda it's extreme it'll just react and
away it goes so bacon bad is the way
forward this is from Nicola when making
cupcakes can you substitute
oil will give you more of a glisten and
a shine and a softness to your cupcakes
but there's no reason why you couldn't
no not at all and play with the oil
types as well you know use the flavored
oil to give something a little bit more
of a kick go to Chris yeah Chris why is
it so hard to find comprehensive
thorough directions on how to whip eggs
to stiff peaks on the internet just
don't add your sugar until right in the
end you get your stiff pigs and then
start adding your sugar slowly and
you'll end up with a beautiful meringue
Sherry silver what are some common
mistakes you make when baking and what
trips you up every time you bake
my most common mistake is I forget the
damn things in the oven and you burn it
I think one of the biggest mistakes
people make in the tent as well is they
forget some ingredients so if you've got
your recipe book in front of you just go
through each one either put something
underneath it and take each line and
weigh it off and double check and put it
in the mixer as you go then you know
you're not going to miss something out
the rest of it missing some of that
recipes are very very common stuff let's
just say Matthew McGuckin yeah I think
that works what does proofing dough even
mean grooming down basically means
putting air in bread leaving it to rise
letting the yeast do its work from Van
Weezer
every time I try to make dough it Cooks
out too dense what am I doing wrong well
first of all Cooks wrong word bakes is
the answer with baking if it's too dense
you've either a not gone off watering as
the dough itself is too dense before
we've even proved it or B your
Chancellor you have improved it long
enough that's a good indication to tell
you that the yeast is that it's full
expense mostly it's got a double in
volume yeah it will bounce back and you
know when it's going in the oven because
you touch it it Springs back and then
don't undercook it because bake it
oh Brew you're letting me down don't
under bake it because if it you do the
middle will be a bit soggy anyway and
then when it gets cold that'll get dense
is put it in a tent so there's only one
way for that to go and it's straight up
and then it opens up the the texture
inside the loaf and then you bake it
it's dead easy that's Ted Roth hand
mixer versus stand mixer which is a
better option hand mixers are really
better for tiny quantities yeah if you
can afford it by a good stand mixer
either way but to be honest a stand mix
is more versatile for what you need
wrecked Raven what's the secret to good
buttercream why can't I ever make it
right
which makes it properly use um I think
you call it confectioners sugar over
here with butter done put a bit of color
or flavor in there with a bit of lemon
zest well that's all the questions hope
you enjoyed it we did yeah and if you've
got any more questions send them through
we'll answer them in the very near
future
bye-bye
[Music]